there's so many theories about kind of
these these characters around the
neighborhood and what their role is
are we right to be intrigued by mrs hart
and what she could possibly be a part of
in the future
yes where did you two move from
how long have you been married and why
don't you have children yet
our story i think what my wife means to
say is that we moved for
move from where married when damn it why
oh arthur stop it stop it
stop it stop it i'm obsessed with this
show
it's so fun and weird and a little
creepy and all of those things
i mean how do you feel like you're part
of the marvel universe i had
no idea what it was i like had no idea
and so every day is another
something you know it's like oh what's
this and no now it's
this it's it's gigantic
it's gigantic and it's international
i mean it's like huge it's huge right
and you probably i mean i i don't know
if you've had the moment where it's
really hit yet because we've kind of
been stuck inside this whole time but
you have you had a particularly
surreal moment of being like oh this is
hitting me i'm part of this
i think it was all of the
all the online presence about it you
know and all the
um all the things that people were
coming up with as to you know what this
meant and what that meant and
um honestly i had no idea i i
did not know from marvel when i started
this so this has all been
a remarkable journey have you ever had
to keep a secret
quite like this when it comes to work
well see i didn't really
no one asked me any questions because no
one knew i was in it
right i didn't get put on the spot at
all
really i am now but there's only so much
i know
you know you get your part and you know
and then if you need to know more i am
like a gnat
when i have a question i will i will ask
200 people until i get the answer so
i did find out probably some disallowed
things
but i when i watch it and i see you know
the little twilight zone
things is what i call them those little
moments i i'm watching it with you guys
you know and
and going oh oh oh and i think it's much
better in black and white too because
it's like
it's more like the twilight zone for me
yeah and you're the one that kind of
sets th that tone
for the time i know i get to do like the
first
crack yeah what did you know about the
show when you came on board like
did somebody approach you and say hey we
want you to be a part of this
it's kind of weird but like hey bear
with me for a second it's going to be
cool like what are they oh
yeah that's exactly what they said to me
that is exactly what they said to me
they said
we want you to be part of this it's kind
of weird it's very hard to explain
but we'll do the best we can and so
basically
uh the director called me he knew me
from theater actually i had just worked
at his theater and
they needed uh someone who knew sitcom
uh because it was the beginning of their
filming
and uh and the others didn't have as
much experience and then they needed
someone who could do drama
which he knew from theater and um and
then they sort of tried to explain it to
me
none of which i understood like none
like zip
and i did it because my great nephew
said aunt debbie if you don't do this i
will never speak to you again
and that's why i did it that's why i did
it and then i walked into this
this thing there's so many theories
about
kind of these these characters around
the neighborhood and what their role is
are we right to be intrigued by mrs hart
and what she could possibly be a part of
in the future
yes
i love that that's you know what i love
that answer
there's more to her than meets the eye
so can we expect possibly
to see you again in the show do you
think if i am not cut
you know you never know what a director
is going to do you know you
never know so i'm very hopeful very
hopeful
the first episode was shot in front of a
live audience which you're no stranger
that what was it like returning to that
format i love
it's it might be my favorite
it's my favorite because it's camera and
a live audience i love theater but in
the sitcom thing for
it's it's different every time you do it
it's like a new little play
every time you do it this one was
different though because
because the live audience was coming to
see
marvel and they were coming to see a
sitcom
and so when we did this started it as a
sitcom you could just feel like
heavy confusion like what
what and they recognize lizzie and paul
but they
they just they were kind of confused and
i
loved it i just loved it how much fun
was it going into this like
50 sitcom realm i felt sort of
you know when i think about it i felt
like sort of being
like a part of history i just felt like
i was part of that you know i don't take
credit for it but
i felt like i was part of it and it was
lovely
there's lots of theories have you been
have you gone down the wormhole on
reddit
or anything like that and started
reading theories about the show yet
no i i have read some you know like on
twitter or whatever
you know i've had people ask me some
very bizarre questions
uh but no i haven't done any of that no
has anyone tweeted you anything that
was like scarily accurate there was one
person
that was kind of very close um
i'm so beyond intrigued
gosh that 70 show wilbur of adorama said
he bought the car
yeah can you top that do you have
anything that can
oh i have everything i have everything
i have my favorite thing the cheese
grate
grater lights in the kitchen i don't
know if you ever realized it but in the
kitchen over the bar
there are cheese graters all in a row
spray painted a bronze color i
took those like with the wires and
everything
i took those i have a lot of kitty
sweaters
and i took um do you want to see one
thing that i have
of course hold on i'm coming i'm coming
i took this oh my god
okay this was sitting in the dining room
it was in the dining room not the dining
room the little den
area that was behind the stairs that i
think we
shot all of maybe three scenes out of
200
it in there um this was sitting in there
and there's a big orange ash tray too
like
like giant ashtray i feel like i asked
this question a lot and
usually people are like no you know i
don't know maybe some wardrobe stuff but
you're like yes i redecorated my whole
house
[Laughter]
no and i actually was thinking about
this the other day i actually i was so
depressed when it ended
i went in and the producer
let me go through and i have so many
slides
that nobody has of that show so at some
point i'm gonna
make them into photographs but i have
all of those too
i know i hate saying goodbye i hate it
so did you take anything from one
division then yes
a thief totally
no no no but this was practical i did
not know i didn't take anything from the
set or anything
i actually didn't think of it or i would
have um
i took a oh do they know i took it
yeah they know it had a shirt it's just
a long shirt it's a long
long shirt that i really liked so i took
that yeah
amazing i want a house tour next time
you